.
TONIGHT, GARY TUCHMAN HAS THE
STORY.
>> Reporter: WHAT YOU WILL SEE
HERE IS NOT A THREAT, BUT IT
SURE LOOKS LIKE IT.
>> 3, 2, 1, GO, GO, MOVE, MOVE,
MOVE!
>> Reporter: SCORES OF PEOPLE
RUNNING.
THE SOCIAL HALL PLUNGING INTO
DARKNESS.
>> YOU HAVE 30 SECONDS TO SAVE
YOUR LIFE.
MOVE!
>> Reporter: WHAT ARE THESE
INNOCENT VICTIMS ABOUT TO DO?
WHAT DO THEY NEED TO DO?
JUST A BIT EARLIER AT THIS
SANCTUARY, THE MEMBERS OF
DALLAS' JEWISH COMMUNITY WERE
TOLD, DO NOT FREEZE.
>> IF YOU CAN GET OUT, GET OUT.
IF YOU CAN'T GET OUT OR LOCK
DOWN, YOU HAVE TO FIGHT FOR YOUR
LIFE.
YOU HAVE LITERALLY NO OTHER
CHOICE.
>> Reporter: THIS IS ACTIVE
SHOOTER AND ACTIVE THREAT
TRAINING FOR THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY HERE.
THE SECURE COMMUNITY NETWORK.
>> THE ACT OF HIDING PRONE AND
PLAYING DEAD IS THE LAST ACT OF
A DESPERATE PERSON.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE CAN ABIDE
BY.
>> Reporter: THE SCN HAS A
COMMAND CENTER IN CHICAGO.
IT WAS HERE WHERE THEY WERE IN
CONTACT WITH THE FBI AND DHS
DURING THE RECENT HOSTAGE
SITUATION IN NEARBY CONLEYVILLE,
TEXAS.
THAT SYNAGOGUE HAD SCN TRAINING
LAST AUGUST.
>> I MET WITH ONE OF THE
HOSTAGES TODAY, AND HE
RE-EMPHASIZED WHAT HE SAID ON
TELEVISION.
THEY ESCAPED, THEY WEREN'T
RESCUED, BECAUSE OF THE TRAINING
THEY RECEIVED.
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF TRAINING
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS
EVENING.
>> Reporter: THE CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION IS OVER.
TIME FOR THE DRILL.
>> WE'RE GOING TO PRACTICE
HIDING, LOCKING DOWN, AND WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE WILL
DO IF WE HAVE TO FIGHT FOR OUR
LIFE.
>> Reporter: PILE UP FURNITURE
AGAINST THE DOOR, TURN OFF THE
LIGHTS.
MAKE IT HARDER FOR THE SHOOTER
TO KILL.
>> LOCK THE ROOM DOWN, TO
PREVENT PHYSICAL ACCESS AS WELL
AS LINE OF SIGHT ACCESS.
>> Reporter: ONCE AGAIN, WHAT
THEY LEARN TO DO.
>> GUNSHOTS ARE COMING DOWN THE
HIGHWAY.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO PANIC.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
GET UP!
GO!
MOVE, MOVE, MOVE!
>> Reporter: THE LIGHTS TURNED
OFF TO FOIL THE TERRORIST'S
VISION.
>> YOU HAVE 30 SECONDS TO SAVE
YOUR LIFE.
MOVE!
>> Reporter: WHEN THE DRILL
ENDS, FURNITURE IS AGAINST THE
DOOR.
>> YOU GUYS DID FANTASTIC.
>> Reporter: AND THE SECURITY
EXPERT ADDED THIS.
BE CREATIVE, LIKE HITTING A
TERRO
TERRORIST ON THE HEAD WITH A
FIRE EXTINGUISHER.
OR SPRAYING IT INTO THEIR EYES.
>> PULL, AIM, SQUEEZE.
SIDE TO SIDE.
WHAT THEY CAN'T SEE, THEY CAN'T
KILL.
OKAY?
THAT'S WHY MY FAVORITE
IMPROVISED WEAPON NEXT TO A FIRE
EXTINGUISHER IS A HOT CUP OF
COFFEE.
>> WHAT HAPPENED IN CONLEYVILLE
WAS FRIGHTENING.
EVERYONE HERE FEELS MUCH MORE
PREPARE.
>> I KNEW NOTHING COMING IN.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY SAID TURN
OFF THE LIGHTS, BARRICADE, RUN,
HIDE, THEY GAVE A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WERE SO CRUCIAL.
>> Reporter: THE RABBI ALSO TOOK
PART IN THE TRAINING.
>> I THINK WE ALL WILL WALK OUT
IN A BETTER POSITION TO DEAL
WITH ANY CRISIS THAT MIGHT COME
OUR WAY.
>> GARY IS WITH ME NOW FROM
DALLAS.
IS IT SAFE TO ASSUME, THE
ORGANIZATION HAS RECEIVED A LOT
MORE REQUESTS FOR THIS KIND OF
TRAINING SINCE THE LATEST
HOSTAGE SITUATION?
>> Reporter: ABSOLUTELY,
ANDERSON.
A HUGE NUMBER OF TRAINING
REQUESTS.
LAST YEAR, THEY TRAINED ABOUT
17,000 PEOPLE, THIS YEAR, THEY
EXPECT POSSI